enjoyment comes from sharing pleasure
with others and in all the things that
we've been talking about it seems that
there's this there's this through line
of other people involved whether it's
difficulty or pleasure that's right you
know there's a there's a study called
the Harvard study of adult development
that's a an 85-year longitudinal study
that followed people who were studying
at Harvard in the late 1930s and then
have followed their spouses and then it
followed their kids over 85 years and it
asked you know what were they doing
through the course of their lives that
predicted them being happy when they
were in their 80s and even their 90s and
he said this is the one thing you need
to know Happiness Is Love full stop love
of the Divine love at your family love
of your friends and love expressed
toward the whole world through the way
that you earn your daily bread happiness
is love it's it's I sound like a John
Lennon at this point but you know it's
true you know all the science comes down
to that